Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain an American action comedy film called
“Barely Lethal”. Watch out and take care!
Prescott Academy is a government-run secret
institution that trains little girls into becoming
assassins. The chief of the organization, Hardman
brings them in as young as ten months old to teach
them everything about life, without guidance from
outside media. Little girls of the Prescott
Academy are trained to be killing machines.
They learn to shoot at three years old with guns
that are taller than them. When they turn five,
they are taught to drive, and by a year, they
can skillfully indulge in a high-speed car chase.
Every day, they practice different forms of
fighting skills, so when they turn into teenagers,
they can be used for several dangerous missions
without being suspected. The number one rule
that Hardman stands by is "no attachments".
Therefore, although the girls are all orphans,
they have never been allowed to form connections
with each other. They aren’t given any names
and are known as their agent numbers.
Currently, the best student in the academy is
number eighty-three. She shoots like a killer
that she is trained to be and fights the best
among everyone. But, the “no attachments” rule
never made sense to her. One day, the girls are
given the task of poking a stuffed toy with a pen.
While the other girls do as told, Eighty-three
holds the toy to her chest. Hardman presents
her as a bad example and tears the toy’s head.
Eighty-three has emotions piling up inside her
that are about to burst one day. As time passes,
she grows into a teenager with outstanding
fighting skills. Her biggest competitor is number
Eighty-four who has always been the second-best
at everything. She despises Eighty-three and
could kill her if they weren’t working for the
same agency. Eight-three is the first one in her
class to be activated, meaning that she is sent on
dangerous missions before all of her classmates.
As usual, Eighty-four is not happy about
it but she has no authority to protest.
After being activated, Eighty-three goes on
several missions. Since she is a teenager,
she is never suspected of being an agent. She
completes all of her tasks with ease impressing
Hardman. However, she still longs for the
normal teenage life that she never got to live.
In one of her missions, she is spying on a target
when she notices a party going on next door.
Seeing the teenagers dance and have fun
makes Eighty-three realize that her life
isn’t normal. She has missed a huge part of her
childhood and doesn’t want her teenage years to
go in vain. Eighty-three decides to flee from
the establishment and its responsibility the
next chance she gets. But before that, she has to
know what being a normal girl actually looks like.
For this, she starts to gather intel on teenage
high school life by watching movies like Mean
Girls, The princess diary, and Clueless. Every
time she is away on a mission, she buys magazines
to secretly read them during boring meetings.
One day, her habit gets her in trouble when
Hardman finds her reading a magazine as he is
briefing her about an important mission.
He orders her to come back to her senses
because the next mission is very dangerous.
An arms dealer and the most dangerous woman
in the mafia, Victoria was located in a city
eight hours ago. She has to be captured alive
within two days or else she will disappear
again. Eighty-four wants to go on the mission,
hoping that it would make her Hardman’s favorite
but Eighty-three is given the task. In the
following scene, we see that Victoria is in
a construction zone with three hostages. She
insults them and takes their blindfolds off.
All of a sudden, the female hostage reveals
that she is Eighty-three. In an instant,
Eighty-three attacks Knox and overpowers all her
henchmen. She ties a hook to Knox that goes up
to an airplane flying overhead. At last, they
are pulled up to the plane, and Eighty-three’s
mission is complete. But since Knox still has
her gun, she points it at her. Eighty-three
cuts the harness and drops into the river below
while Knox is pulled inside the airplane. When
Hardman notices Eighty-three’s absence, he tries
to contact her on a device attached to her wrist.
Eighty-three gets out of the water and hears him.
However, she doesn’t reply, knowing that this
is her only chance to escape her old life.
She throws her watch away and decides to never
look back. Back in the airplane, Hardman is
told that they aren’t receiving any visuals
or audio from her. He declares her “inactive” and
continues interrogating Victoria. Following that,
Eighty-three creates an entirely new identity
under the name Megan. She also transfers into
a high school in Newton and finds a family to stay
with through a website. At the airport, the family
comes to pick her up. It consists of the mother,
Mrs. Larson, her son Parker and her sarcastic
teenage daughter Liz. Liz is not too happy about
Megan’s arrival and has a hard time adjusting
with her around the house. She finds it weird that
Megan is excited about normal things like riding
the school bus. Still, to please her mother,
she agrees to help Megan around the school.
On her first day at school, Megan dresses up in a
ridiculous outfit, making everyone stare at her.
Only a few minutes in, a bully named Gooch calls
her “fresh meat” as everyone laughs. To make her
feel better, Liz gives her less patterned clothes
to wear. During the morning assembly, she is
supposed to talk in front of everyone as a foreign
exchange student. Before going to the stage,
she meets a geeky kid named Roger who manages the
A/V for the school’s band. As per the movies she
has watched, Megan declares him a nerd. She is
introduced to the entire school but they make fun
of her, calling her names. Soon, they start asking
her to go back to Canada where she came from.
When the chanting gets louder, the school’s band
leader Cash interrupts the crowd with a song.
He is the most popular guy in the school and is
liked by many. Megan is also instantly attracted
to him. During the lunch break, some cheerleaders
call her to eat with them but she refuses,
assuming that they are mean like the cheerleaders
from her favorite movies. In biology class,
she again meets Roger and makes friends with him.
He seems to be attracted to her but all Megan can
focus on is Cash. The next day, she is assigned
as Cash’s lab partner. However, other girls from
the class ask her to choose another partner,
wanting Cash for themselves. After the class,
the girls tell Megan that Cash likes girls
who play the school’s mascot. Megan fails to
realize that they are trying to set her up and
goes to audition to be the school’s mascot.
She is selected instantly and called to practice
for the next game. During the practice, a group of
masked men run towards her and try to kidnap her.
Megan uses her skills to easily overpower them,
surprising everyone around her. She had
thought that the masked people were agents
sent by Hardman but it turns out they are guys
from a rival college trying to cause trouble.
By the time she realizes this, everyone is filming
her. They upload the video on social media,
much to her horror. In Prescott’s base, Victoria
is being held and interrogated by Hardman.
She is also aware that his way of stealing a
good childhood from young girls is wrong. She
calls him out for it but the man insists that
he is doing it for a good cause. Victoria also
shows special interest in number Eighty-four
and is planning to use her to escape. They
soon find out about the viral video of Megan and
assume she is now working for a rival group.
The next day at school, everyone is talking about
Megan’s outstanding fighting skills. She turns
into one of the popular girls overnight. Her day
gets even better when Cash calls her to his band
practice after school. When she reaches there,
she meets Roger and talks to him while waiting for
Cash. Roger loves her personality and registers
that they have a lot in common. But Megan is too
busy drooling over Cash to see that he likes her.
Later, she is invited to a high school party that
her bully Gooch is throwing at his house. Megan
is beyond excited because she has only heard of
such parties in movies. While returning home that
day, she is kidnapped by people from Prescott.
Hardman has assumed that she is working for a
rival establishment and refuses to believe it
when she tells him that she just wants to have a
normal life. He injects her with a truth drug and
finds out she is actually telling the truth.
Hardman feels entitled to her life since he
taught her everything she knows. He orders her
to return to base in two days. Following that,
his people dump her on the front porch of the
house to make Megan look like she's just drunk.
When Megan meets Roger the next time, she invites
him to Gooch’s party. But since his father is
strict about parties, he refuses to go. Megan
would feel better if he was there since he is her
only friend in the school. Later that night, Megan
comes to the party with Liz, who was forced by her
mother to accompany her. To Megan's surprise,
Eighty-four is also at the party, now going
by the name Heather. Megan thinks Hardman sent
Heather to keep an eye on her but Heather doesn’t
confirm or deny the claim. Roger also comes to the
party looking for Megan but is disappointed to see
her kissing Cash. By the end of the night,
Cash asks her to be his homecoming date.
The next morning, Megan gets on the school bus to
see that Hardman is disguised as the driver. He is
there to warn her that Victoria has escaped from
Prescott and is planning to take revenge on her.
He offers her to return to Prescott but Megan
refuses. Later, we see her and Liz driving to
school when they are pursued by a masked assassin.
While in a car chase, Megan tells Liz the truth
about her past life. They eventually crash
in a junkyard along with the assassin’s car.
The assassin is lost but Megan recognizes her
to be Heather by the scent of her perfume.
Liz is in the hospital after the crash.
Megan wants to leave before more people get
hurt because of her but Liz thinks that Megan
trying to abandon the family would be worse.
Starting that day, they get along well. Megan
tells Liz everything about her life as an agent.
They shop outfits for homecoming together and
get each other ready for the special night.
Liz goes out with Gooch, who has changed after
spending time with her at the party. Meanwhile,
Chase and Megan go together. Megan had thought
that the night would be special but Chase hardly
talks to her. After spending some time with him,
she realizes that his entire personality is being
popular. She dumps him and goes to Roger, asking
him for a dance. To her surprise, he declines and
turns to his date for the night, Heather. The
girls argue about who gets to be his date and
eventually get into a fight. They wrestle around
the venue, destroying the decorations. Eventually,
they end up in the kitchen where Heather is about
to stab Megan. Liz sneaks up on Heather and stabs
her in the leg with a corn dog stick. Then, Megan
hits Heather over the head and knocks her out.
Following that, the girls run back home to
see that Victoria and her people have taken
Mrs. Larson and Parker hostage. Megan fights
them efficiently until they capture Liz. She
stops resisting for the family’s safety but still
has hope that Hardman will come to save her.
Victoria laughs at her for being so naive and
reveals that she was the very first Prescott girl,
number one. Like Megan, she also left Prescott for
robbing her of her childhood. She challenges Megan
to a one-on-one fight and defeats her easily.
Suddenly, Hardman arrives with reinforcements
to help Megan and capture Victoria. They break in
and knock out Victoria with a tranquilizer gun.
Megan hugs Hardman, thanking him for the help. In
the last scene, she stops Roger on his drive home
and brings him with her to a helicopter ride.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.